yo
bootleg head podcast man with the homie
price yo yo yo yo yo
formerly price tag right uh
price welcome to the show man
congratulations on on the uh the new
project
appreciate you um color colored is the
name of the project this is like kicking
off the whole new wave the whole new
like
you know branch of your career thanks
um explain to me the
thought process of i mean audio push is
always going to be audio push but in
fact
but having to do like like what what
inspired you to to go solo for a project
or
is there i mean are you are you into
octane i know you guys are still cool
but like
are you guys still technically audio
push right yeah most definitely like we
we'll always be audio push you know what
i mean um
that's my brother's [ __ ] his [ __ ] was
12. right right
but um we've also been audio pushed
non-stop
for 10 plus years since i was 17
you know yeah or something around there
like
actually longer than that to be real
[ __ ] before we got popping we got signed
at that time
but i'm just saying that to say it's
been a long time coming since we've like
told our own story
you know we've been having since we
first were walking up on you in arizona
vegas is when i first met you it was
right facts oh lord yeah
vegas dog since [ __ ] was popping in
2010 oh yeah
in the back you feel me but um even
since then
you know uh we've always had to just
like fuse our story in a sense
and that should just you know it's only
so much you can do with that like we
order
i got two sons you want to do you want
to tell your story i got
unfiltered un you know raw yeah what i'm
saying we got
as much as me and my brother just alike
in so many ways we also
aren't liking right fully different
views and a lot of different things you
know and i feel like in the music
and just this is the chance for me to
like fully express it
but yeah for sure so um like you said
you have
uh i feel like you always have kind of
been like the more outspoken
like out of you and you're are you an
octane like i feel like you're
i know where you stand on a lot of
things
you're very opinionated yeah so when i
saw you announce this i was like oh
that's dope like
i really want to hear what this [ __ ]
sounds like and it came out really i hit
you like the album the
dope body work it's i know it's very
tough like
to deliver like that when there's like
people
people might be like ah you know like
exactly it's very tough to
to deliver and over exceed the
expectations because i was like yeah i'm
gonna check it out but i listened to it
i was like oh this [ __ ] is nice
most definitely especially with all the
like
this out right now like with all the you
know all the music like that you found
yeah
man it's it was like it was a conscious
um
intentional decision that i made like
you know
one just making this my direction
my sound you know what i mean um and my
message
but um and then even with just this
being the first project like because
i got a i got another album drop in
in january you're staying independent
right for sure completely
um most definitely that's a part of
everything we're doing that's a part of
color that's part of the message
um but yeah like
to put colored out knowing that this was
just like i'm gonna just jab y'all
like let me just you know not get up
you feel me like now i'm gonna put you
down like
that's the that was the intentional
thing you know i knew color like songs
like mufasa and things like
you know they weren't gonna be easy to
digest but the people that were able to
digest it were going to be fed yeah i
was going to ask you like um
give me the breakdown on the name
colored and
um you know obviously we know that is
an old way that old people would refer
to black people
you know what i'm saying it's almost
like calling asian people oriental it's
like a very
dated like borderline racist thing to
say
you know what i'm saying but but what
what what is the you know the way it's
spelled kind of break down the meaning
of that
yeah so um it was just
you know when before quarantine even
happened like actually at like the
beginning of this year
um i just knew like
going into this year octane was actually
making solo music for he was the first
one to start making solo music i
remember octane was doing all kinds of
[ __ ] he was like a photographer and yeah
she was dropping videos before she so
yeah i didn't even know that
yeah back in the g he was like dropping
you know he drops a couple
uh solo videos and stuff but um saying
that to say
like coming into the year i knew that i
was like going to take these steps
and um i knew that everything i was
going to stand for the brand i was going
to build
was just had to be black as [ __ ] right
you know what i mean without it being
black as [ __ ] you know or just being all
like
just extra ink2 in your face
um i feel like the same way not the same
way but how like [ __ ] you know that's
just a part of like
the average you know color melanoids
vernacular that lives in the united
states like
to me i wanted to make the word color
be used in a better light like not that
nigga's used in a better light but it's
just used more freely
freely than what it was like the way it
was created
you know and so i feel like colored of
all things because it's
a actual beauty in being color like
that's not a bad like [ __ ]
is some [ __ ] you like created or
like a world you just you know whatever
but being colored i actually get charged
from the sun this is actually
a superpower i have it's not a bad thing
right
yeah no melanin is yours i win being
colored you know i mean it's not even
like
that's just not a science we're not even
talking like opinion
so that was something that just like
i was like you know what i'm about to
i'm gonna finish that
and um just the clrd was just you know
it was like it was god man
the branding like all that [ __ ] was just
like coming to me i wasn't even
asking for it once i just got in harmony
and like
got on the path it literally just
started falling i just wasn't
i was just trusting my god feeling you
know no gut feelings god feeling
yeah i mean and you've been through the
entire industry
gauntlet a couple of times 100
because there's the first the first go
around when you guys you know we're
doing the young boy [ __ ]
exactly and were you guys who were you
guys tied to initially at interscope we
did two
yeah you guys did two different
interscope runs i still have a i still
have a black and white eight by twelve
autographed photo of you and octane from
like 2010.
with [ __ ] somewhere right shout out
to
[ __ ] all the people who ate off for
that first deal
shout out to y'all yeah but it's just
crazy because um
you've like you said two two runs
through interscope
right under obviously much different
circumstances yeah
um and you know
some like like some people don't got it
in them to keep going with this [ __ ] 100
percent
because because you guys could could
have taken that last go round with
with the hs 87 wave and and even like
but you guys
you know much pr props to the to the
good vibe tribe project like you guys
still were putting out incredible music
yeah but i feel like
when you're like put out so much [ __ ]
like
and and like you guys obviously have had
some mild commercial success but never
really like
blue exactly like i feel like once come
as you are came out i thought it was
over
yeah i was like oh this [ __ ] is this is
undeniable
like the shine video was so crazy like
but
um talk about that like like did
did you ever flirt with the idea of of
moving on from music at all
um never like fully
moving on it was just like that's how i
got into business though
right in entrepreneurship like because i
would never
like move on for music because i've been
doing music since i was eight years old
so before i was making money off of
music i love making music so that's
something like i'ma always do
i just had to take away the pressure of
making money from the [ __ ]
i'm not stupid you know what i mean i'm
a hustler so
the moment i had to really realize like
okay the reason why this [ __ ]
stresses me the [ __ ] out is because we
have millions of views
thousands of thousands and thousands of
fans right
but we're not rich like we're not like
comfortable we're not
living like we should be i don't [ __ ] my
money off i'm not addicted to no crazy
like
smoke weed you know i'm not like a idiot
so why
the [ __ ] aren't we up why aren't y'all
why ain't it going crazy other than
people [ __ ] us in deals i was gonna
say was it do you think that's what it
was
you guys had shitty deals 100 um
i mean yeah both i mean our first deal
we got
our first deal was like um almost 800
000 and me and our team split 15 racks
we took
15 racks back to the ie 7 500 back to
the ie wait wait wait wait wait
so it was 800 000 deal 800 000
and you guys signed to a production
company we didn't know the game didn't
know nobody was a production company
they got to touch the money first
obviously so whatever the initial real
events was whatever that two three
hundred thousand phone whatever the [ __ ]
wasn't negotiated thank you
cleaned up and we got 15 racks wow to
split
and it took 7 500 today and for me [ __ ]
i thought
[ __ ] we was good who was that it's my
cousin
[Music]
[ __ ] pissing
game bro these kids now like well back
then i feel like y'all were doing like a
lot of 18 and up parties like no
not even that don't even matter bro the
shows we were doing
[ __ ] was doing thousands like shows
with thousands
of people like and at a low we were
doing an
800 capacity [ __ ] show with kids and
some wild [ __ ] like that
we was doing [ __ ] big shows every
other like at least twice a week and
whatnot make a long story short
one the internet wasn't like it is now
like i was like myspace
you know and so how was it the social
thing was not even a thing for real so
like the aspect of
fully becoming like these mega stars
like like a trippy red
can now was but [ __ ] being a mega star
the money
these [ __ ] do [ __ ] 10 shows these
[ __ ] is millionaires now like back
then
it wasn't that and it was just a
different game we didn't know no better
the the um appreciation for black
music and rap wasn't where it was at we
were still competing with
even katy perry yo back i was gonna say
back then when y'all were like bubbling
at first it was like pit bull and lady
gaga yeah
all that [ __ ] that was it was it was
one of the dark ages
of music black eyed peas we were black
these whack ass they
was getting compared to black eyed
people they were making [ __ ] you
know
they had somebody had some big records
like i got a feeling but i i
bro it's cuz i lived in vegas at that
time right and that's when everything in
vegas changed
where every time you go to the club you
wouldn't hear rap it was all about the
fist pump 128 bpms
and then neo started making whack ass
[ __ ]
all these r b [ __ ] started
making chris brown started making whack
ass [ __ ] yeah
start going to a weird place it was like
everybody was making
[ __ ] whack dance music and some of
that [ __ ] was begging forever it was a
bop
they had bob city but they definitely
would get into a place even us as
created we were getting to a place where
we were trying to force that because
they were
that was what was right pop that was
what was
being told in first time lmfao oh my god
they wanted them
oh my god and uh you know all them type
of people that's who we were getting
compared to like yo
y'all i'm not sure what's worse lmfao or
anything with a
like i'm i'm not sure like is it lil
pump or is it lmfao but
it's tomatoes and tomatoes to me i
really
love this song gucci gang as much as i
don't [ __ ] with it i like
i like boss i don't like little pup
nothing he does the dude
hey that song was a big gucci game you
seen him just like get up on there and
uh support trump
at the right time let him get called
little pimp and after that i turned it
off because there was nothing else that
you
need to say like you got you didn't even
say your name right
like you played them on purpose it's
silly
but we could definitely get into that as
well too at some point no we will
um no but it's crazy because you guys
went through all these errors of music
some of it was microwavable but like and
then the hs87 wave hit
hit boy becomes the biggest producer in
the world yeah
uh that was what [ __ ] 2011 is when watch
the throne came out
yeah so that's like 2012 and then 2012
is when
he got the deal by that time you would
already um soon move on from the
production deal originally
yeah but like so around like just to
give like a quick little boom like
after we like let's say like 2010
you know what i'm saying we were [ __ ]
two
three songs into the deal [ __ ] wasn't
really trying to give us no money
i had real relationships chris brown
invited us on like this huge ass tour
at this restaurant out here in hollywood
he looked me and my face was like man
y'all come on the tour man y'all good
all y'all gotta do is get a tour bus and
y'all good for every day and they have
bread for us we just had to get a bus
and we didn't know the game interscope
wouldn't even pay for the bus it was 60
racks
it was stupid little petty [ __ ] like
that that like we didn't know no better
saying that to say um we but i knew
enough to be like yo this [ __ ] is whack
you feel me and then
uh me and octane like they start kind of
like turning us against each other they
start getting weird
early but this is my brother so if we
were never able to do nothing it was
always like get in the room and chop it
up like [ __ ] what's good
right [ __ ] is out you feel me and so
that's what we did
i let [ __ ] know like yo i'm up out of
here like i ain't [ __ ] with this
production that [ __ ] none of this [ __ ]
no more
um we had the option at the time
interscope everybody had left
you know that signed this all this [ __ ]
so we had the option to stare go
we left moved back to the hood with the
little bit of bread i had i moved back
literally
to the hood too like i was around the
corner from the block like
and um i had a little bread so like
in the hood we were stars everywhere we
go eat the [ __ ] so let's pop in
make a long story shirt we made i'll
start producing it and we did a song
called throw it back in the song called
wrap it up
that both did a million views and [ __ ]
on youtube and [ __ ] remember
you feel me as kids so this is no hit
boy no no no it's coming or nothing
[ __ ] in rialto
me producing it my [ __ ] doing our
thing
and that started like making even just
like the hit boy just [ __ ] like
our brothers and [ __ ] even respecting
these like [ __ ]
we was doing a lot more even so i
started getting around hit boy more
outside of this [ __ ] before he
was doing his deal we been knowing here
right right
so when he first got his deal you know
he called me like on me when jimmy iveen
wanted to
when he offered him the deal he called
me i remember i was in the bay
he called me and he was like yo i'm
about to do this [ __ ]
come move it in the guy when he moved
with him you know and uh where he got a
little apartment like north hollywood
when i tell you it's [ __ ] hit boyd and
smack the baddest [ __ ] in the game
i'm not even
here just know this man didn't
crack the goats at these like all the so
he [ __ ] rihanna
i don't know about that
but that nigga's the goat i'm just
saying i said cause i remember being in
this little apartment when we had our
mansion she was different but
when i was in his apartment like i lived
in this i was sleeping on his couch so
i'm watching
i'm waking up to the girls walking out
like oh [ __ ]
like damn that's that's
so it was a while a little time but um
that's my brother that's why i could
talk that [ __ ]
shout out to hippo no yeah he didn't go
to so many levels but
hey well we're gonna get you i wanna get
to the house a hit too but um
all right so he hit y'all hs 87 to me
was
something that was dope it was like
y'all can't money i forget the girl's
name
beat mac the queen shot yeah mac the
queen beat care g
right [ __ ] uh hey banger
um what the [ __ ] is this uh k roosevelt
k roosevelt yeah come on man okay
roosevelt's still going crazy yo he's
fine
um but now but like what do you think
what do you think went wrong with hs87
or why do you think it didn't work out
like
i i thought it was going to obviously i
thought it was gonna be crazy man listen
hsa7
was like the biggest [ __ ] ever which we
didn't even realize until
after when people be telling us how we
were when we walked in rooms and like
the perception which we
know you know i mean but the real reason
that
i personally think it didn't work out
other than just divine timing
um was just hip boy was the biggest
producer in the world
as well as hip boy can actually rap and
make dope music
you know what i'm saying he was really
inspired to make
you know um his own music you know do a
solo thing
and i think it was a lot of people in
the his corner and in his ear no i don't
think i know
it was a lot of people in this corner in
his ear and the wrong people in his
corner in his ear that just was just
giving them wrong advice
in game you know simple as that that
like
um on what he should have been doing
with the budget and then we from naive
we kids like that don't know [ __ ] [ __ ]
just get
broke like i remember like hit boy being
at my cribs
spending the night before i remember hit
boy being at our producer's crib
stugging like him ain't always been up
and rich either you know so
when that [ __ ] start getting that crazy
bread like he trusting these people
you know so when they not telling that
[ __ ] to put
200 000 at radio behind k roosevelt
as he should have that do me now record
was out of here that you know
or when they not telling this [ __ ] to
put you know 200 000
to whatever [ __ ] anything whatever
behind shine or whatever
because he's not knowing to and
obviously he's not finished
so i think it was [ __ ] like i think it's
i told hit this i told him that i think
he's improved so much as an emcee
and i feel like he's he's taken huge
strides in that direction
yeah i feel like initially he
[Music]
he had you can't money
i feel like he could have eased into the
rap and [ __ ] a little bit
slower mm-hmm you know what i'm saying
if that makes sense yeah 100
i mean because hip boy is rapping
better than everyone now no no he could
rap his like i just like
initially i feel like he he came into
the game like it went from him being the
biggest producer in the game
to him it almost felt like solely
focusing on rapping
yeah and and he was and it was like all
right well which it wasn't a bad idea
because he had good news no he had a
great record bro then the [ __ ] dropped
jay-z interview like well we got jay's
interview was crazy and that [ __ ] went
so
crazy that you would be foolish to not
like go full speed ahead you know what i
mean but
i think like me my cousin was just
banging a
[ __ ] hip boy versus going crazy this
nigga's a nut right like his right hand
he's killing it now that's right
this whole project he dropped he threw
out two projects this year the [ __ ] with
dom and his solo [ __ ]
but the reason why i feel like he's
going so crazy now is because
he's the where he's at in the production
i feel like low-key
when you get to the point where you're
like
as big as he was and then
it almost feels like
he ha he he's got a chip on his shoulder
again because
i feel like people stop mentioning him
in those conversations that he should
always be mentioned in
yeah and i think it was because he was
so focused on hs87
right and and and and that whole era of
his career that it took away from hit
boy the producer so now i feel like he's
just
and he's been on his [ __ ] for like dude
and i'm gonna tell you bro
really really not just this year by the
way no no every year hey boy got at
least 10 places
but the thing is too like at that time
specifically we were really on some [ __ ]
too where we was like yo we finna
challenge the game
the beat sounded wild like granted now
[ __ ] beats and [ __ ] sound like what we
was doing bro i remember i was
i was at y'all's crib in uh encino or
where was it at
tarzan tarzana i was over there bro and
you guys played me grinding my whole
life
yeah and i was blown away
it was like the hardest [ __ ] i ever
heard yeah i was like this is the craze
this is the chris
since i grind in from the clips this
[ __ ] is so hard like
literally some of the beasts i mean the
beast was so nutty that like people
didn't get them you didn't get it and so
like a person it just raps too crazy and
so it's just going over your head like
[ __ ] daylight you know what i'm
saying like that was how the beats were
you know even though we left the beats
were crazy listen real music
[ __ ] loved them everyone loved
them but
the people the people who aren't music
like
kids that are in their [ __ ] car going
to school that want mcdonald's on the
way
don't understand the beast didn't
understand what he was doing that's why
everything that man is touching now is
translating he gets it he gots the rosie
crack the code
yeah you guys you think later on like
looking back people have kind of caught
on to it you know like a movie will come
out and then like later on it's like a
cult classic
yeah but it didn't do nothing but make
the people who did catch it like only go
in
like embrace hit boy more and bracelets
more that really did [ __ ] with us
right embrace like the people who are
catching it late they're just coming and
[ __ ] with us now
and the people who are who you know
who aren't catching and never caught it
just is what it is
yeah you guys had a crazy nucleus at
that house where everybody was just
working in different rooms
and the illest [ __ ] like i can
yo what's some of your favorite house of
hit memories
for people who don't know hip boy had a
crib in tarzana
everyone lived there we had a crib
everybody had a creature let's be clear
man cause uh
you know we we we we had brad go into
that crib man no that [ __ ] was crazy
it was just the environment the creative
environment of that [ __ ] was wild
yeah we had a um we did have the
[ __ ] biggest and dopest i'll say not
biggest but i'll say
dopest compound
and had easily the biggest parties in la
them years that we were doing it like
without a doubt like for sure
that's what was some of my favorite
moments other than like your boy just
coming downstairs and
telling me hey [ __ ] man
nah it's going to be here in an hour
just wild [ __ ] like that throw me away
you know what i mean until like make
sure you tell me like don't
don't invite nobody make sure don't
nobody pull up because
this wild ass person is coming you know
what i'm saying and only
i can luckily be in there and this
person that you know [ __ ] likes that
like hip boy is [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] like that's dude
that's nigga's got did you guys ever
record on some [ __ ]
and then he ended up having to break it
to y'all like hey guys sorry rihanna
took this one
or hey guys sorry oh man that wasn't
beyonce
like [ __ ] do you remember an example
listen watch this i mean
[ __ ] in paris was a whole another the
homie had a whole different song
chili chill had a whole different song
to that like we always
that would always happen let me think of
a [ __ ] song um
i don't know but that would always
happen you know or
just [ __ ] man it would be sometimes
songs i can't really think of it because
it would be like all we did was create
so sometimes we would set the platform
for certain records that like [ __ ]
sometimes we would get take off songs
but we wouldn't give a [ __ ] we were
it was it was to benefit the game so
it's like [ __ ] if the [ __ ] getting
placed or
whatever we was just creating you know
so um i can't even remember it was so
many [ __ ] moments
but my favorite moments though i gotta
say was like our parties because i
remember like literally like i would be
standing we had this wild-ass balcony
where where the dj would be dj and i'd
be on the mic
like hit boy be up there like like i got
a wild ass picture with me
hit boy frank ocean james fondleroy
travis scott
whoever else the [ __ ] is on that balcony
from way over there travis got [ __ ]
low-ass hair
yeah you know what i'm saying when
travis was opening up for casey veggies
when frank ocean was coming to [ __ ]
parties
like you can't get frank ocean to go to
coachella right now
you know what year was that uh probably
like 2013
you know sometime around there um but
just like the people we will be watching
like
big sean walking up about us the game
[ __ ] chris brown like all these
[ __ ] was just in our front yard you
know what i mean
at the party we wasn't even inviting
people half the time
[ __ ] just had to be there because we
was having the craziest parties
the whole ie slide and that's what was
making the parties this [ __ ] because we
was bringing
ie you feel me that was bringing a
different everybody drive out
different energy though more more more
interested in having fun
ghetto yeah turn [ __ ] was turned
[ __ ] doing a wild problem doing
while [ __ ] the party ax problem next
time if you ever do whatever then you do
a problem
ask him the netty ash that his netty ass
moments at the crib he was my favorite
person coming
oh yeah the problem used to be crazy
amazing that's my dog i remember doing
to a problem the problem is uh
yeah he's a fun guy he parties i mean
listen welcome to mollywood
you know what i'm saying that was that
all you gotta do is just [ __ ] you
know
listen just listen to the album yeah so
it was just a dope time like above
everything man hey boy like
because regardless of like the mistakes
that we all make just growing in this
game this game is a very
dark and slithery game if you get in the
wrong [ __ ] and once you get to a certain
height
meaning and when you say that i can go
into context because people always say
that so to the kids that's
watching the [ __ ] it's just about
intention everybody that's in this game
isn't in it for the right reason you
know what i'm saying so because you got
good we rolled up as well or something
um but
everybody's not in it for the right
reason so you got some people who's dark
and want to cheat you out of deals or
divide homies up so that they can get
closer to this person that looks like
the biggest producer so they can have
all to say so so they can be the one to
have the
30 or whatever it gets slithery so
above everything we maintain the
brotherhood like we maintain like we
never get out here and get to smutting
each other and doing the wild nutty [ __ ]
nobody ever really truly cheated nobody
like him boy ain't never cheat us
like he just didn't know the game you
know what i mean and that's just it is
what it is like
everybody ain't like everybody's not
just
out to be busy everybody's not barry
gordy because they're [ __ ] just
super musically talented you can't
expect that all the time you know
nah for sure do you think uh like as
as a homie like how dope is it to see
like the year that he's having man
because man it's historical i could man
cry i probably i don't know if i have or
not you know what i mean that's my real
brother we didn't cry
in the studio before we really had
moments so like me like seeing his son
you know what i'm saying just seeing
what he didn't been through like his boy
didn't been through some wild [ __ ]
behind closed doors that's that happened
within these years that's also charged
him up it's also made him
treat look at [ __ ] different you know
he didn't really went through some wild
[ __ ] you feel me so
i'm just like so proud and just so
inspired you know that's always been my
big homie you know what i'm saying i
just said like
when i was first making beats that [ __ ]
was laying on his bed [ __ ]
with his laptop on his chest like not
even paying me no mind cause my beats
were so weak
and i was just going through like
weirdos sounds and he just was like
i actually had a dope beat but i had a
weak ass sound in here he just was like
sound selection is key little honey
that's what he literally looked over and
told me that night never forgot that
[ __ ]
i think about it every time i created
music are you are you still producing
hell yeah man how much how much of the
album did you produce
um i did like two or three beats i did
maya though featuring
dope uh culture yeah and um i did uh
watermelon with tony stiff so i did like
two or three and then on my new [ __ ] i
got a lot of
[ __ ] yeah so what's um okay so the album
is out
i you know you've been getting a lot of
love yeah
man is it is it hard like is it harder
to go through this like uh
you know we're in a in a world now where
there's just very like like two or three
people that could really change your
life
and they're like carl cherry and whoever
the [ __ ] is carl cherry at apple music
yeah you know and it's like it kind of
sucks
because there's very like little room to
just like
like you got it you got to be like a
cool guy almost you got to be in that
cool guy club
to get into like a lot of these
playlists and it's
i i think it's i think it's wack but
um is it hard like for you to try to
thrive in this environment
like as you know being indie now being
solo now and trying to still you know
compete
in that world because it's a hard world
to compete in man 100 it is
um i think you're absolutely right about
it being like a game where you got to
know
these people yeah and it's really wet
because what if carl doesn't like you
yeah or what if you met somebody at a
party co-part about it'd be so much
deeper than carl would be
like no i'm not i'm not trying but no no
no no no no no no no this that's so
crazy i'm piggybacking on what you're
saying
it don't even get to carl because
two steps under carl you might have
[ __ ] pissed them off the wrong way
that could have been a [ __ ] that
wasn't even in music it just gets wild
and so
um the number one thing that i
made sure i kept in my psyche and just
my spirit while doing everything i'm
doing creating my music being solo
paying for videos doing my real life
doing everything i'm doing
was just pure intentions is just knowing
what i'm like my message why i'm doing
it which
is purely to like like teach
and inspire like freedom leadership
ownership in my people like i got enough
people that literally [ __ ] with me
that's just gonna listen
that like if even if that's 100 people
that i knew if i put it in music forum
it would have just inspired them and
turned them up
and that's how i was coming bro like i
ain't even wasn't even really trippy
because i've had it at the highest
heights
as far as like billboard premieres
first video to play on revoked like the
third video was biggie
it was a video that wasn't in english
shine yeah it's the third video to ever
play
worldwide on revolt i didn't have the
biggest premieres
shout out to revolt i don't know who
watches it anymore
shout out to puffy you know shout out to
naughty shout out to the whole team it
was so many [ __ ]
we know now revolt early on was so fire
we know the original team yeah you know
what i mean the dana's the [ __ ] the
elves the
real original team that's our people but
um
we so i've had the highest heights of
[ __ ] premieres and i've had it where
just me and i can't drop the [ __ ] on
[ __ ] soundcloud or something god know
and then had a song that's streaming
[ __ ] millions of
streams that we don't own the masters to
because we know the game and our manager
owns it
however we just dropped that on a low
scale and it boomed we didn't
so it's like first i know i got records
like low key was just like everybody
yeah travis and we got relationship i
really have
i saw travis reposted your your album
you requested album man which in 2020 is
huge
my man's got his own mcdonald's meal you
know what i'm saying gary my son went
crazy about it my son was like dad
travis you know what i mean that's my
brother you still talk to travis yeah
yeah like we ain't like we ain't like an
everyday thing that's my brother yeah
right if i call him you know enough
times he gonna answer you for me that's
that nigga's huge
baby so i don't even take it personally
i remember the first time i met him
him and casey veggies were on the road
together and he opened up for casey
in scottsdale exactly and then now you
know jesus that part
it's crazy i mean we was [ __ ] jeezy was
opening for us
and yeah i mean i mean a lot of people
was open
ty was opening up you know what was the
uh tour you were
on in when i saw you guys in florida
it was after coming it was on school
school
i was thinking that's what i said it was
scuba q vince isaiah shot
that was a crazy tour that was mine
mind-blowing life-changing
but that was that's what it is my
intentions has been pure luckily i've
been just blessed i got an incredible
partnership
and through my partnership my music been
speaking like because that's what i've
been doing like i ain't
i'm funding everything so funny like
everything i've been funded so it's like
you got an investor you said you got a
business partner is that kind of the guy
putting up the
hell some bread or you're coming with
your own bread bro like that's my
business partner
in my endeavors outside of music outside
of music when it comes to your [ __ ]
it's my music is solely me like
you know what i'm saying having to go
through it like damn let me
listen man take them let's do this
camera
let's make it this long then because you
know cuz yo you said something yesterday
about the voting [ __ ]
yeah okay so yeah
from what i read on your story you would
pretty much said i'm gonna just go out
here and vote just to show y'all don't
matter
that is fluke that is fluke or something
to that point
so can you please elaborate on that but
then i also posted after which i will
elaborate on that but then i'll suppose
that i was joking and i wasn't going to
vote
um okay wait you didn't vote no oh okay
why not okay so let's let's get in there
yeah let's go let's go
so i have posted that let me take these
like mentos um
because they keep jingling and [ __ ]
and it's 20 20 and we don't be in my
immediate training [ __ ] man
we're doing what we want to do but um
so i have posted oh like how we're
taking blint's
mid interview this is so good it's
awesome um
so i posted yo i'm going to go vote just
to show you
how flue get it that is just flute and
for like 30 minutes i
almost convinced myself that i was and i
was like what are you doing
cut it out and then i posted that i
wasn't going to vote in
um that i'm not going to
participate and encourage my followers
that y'all don't have to be
bullied into participating in something
that isn't true to you
if you do not connect if you do and i'm
talking about on the presidential status
if you want to go and vote
for the lower level voting city voters
councils
things of that nature different like
props and laws
100 but i'm talking about a presidential
level which everyone was campaigning for
that's what i'm talking about but on
that same ballot is all the local [ __ ]
100
that affects a lot of [ __ ] 100 so
if you're going but i'm speaking about
you because if you go and vote
so when you're saying if i'm not voting
for a month
if you go and vote you don't have to
vote
yeah president exactly that's what so
that's what i'm saying you don't have to
yeah you can leave whatever on that
ballot empty that you don't want to vote
my point
so if it's if you feel inspired to go
out and vote for
anything that you feel inspired for
which was my part of my post
and then by all means go vote but you
also have the right especially
us color people mom illinois anybody
there are american africans in this
country you 100 have the right to
not vote just as much you have the right
to vote you know i mean especially if
neither one of these people resonate
with you so let me ask you a question
though dude
[ __ ] with trump or biden neither do i
but i really don't [ __ ] with trump
yeah right so let me ask you this though
but like
if you think about okay let's say
hypothetically speaking we rewind how
long has we've been recreational out
here it's been like
almost 10 years right no record
recognition it's probably been like
a little over two years uh yeah 2016's
yeah yeah exactly where it's just like
smoke outside
so so if you think about it right
even if you go before before medicinal
right people had to go out and vote for
that
to happen yeah right and so there's a
lot of people who
might be in jail right now had that not
gotten past
we can't walk like if you go i mean you
know this you've been on the road
you can't walk around louisville
kentucky with weed the way you can walk
around
l.a my first time ever going to jail my
only time i've ever been to jail just to
piggyback was in atlanta for
literally a point zero zero one a weed i
can't even grab as much weed out of here
that i had
so what i'm saying is those those things
like actually affect people we know
100 right and i do think too there's
another conversation to be had about the
president [ __ ]
but i think if you have any sort of
platform if you choose not to vote
that's on you but i just don't think
it's very
i don't think you have to promote not
voting
right because even if you like i i
i agree with you about the presidential
[ __ ] neither candidate was inspiring
one of them though is hitler seen
no because i've seen you on instagram
talk like like having run-ins with trump
supporters
yeah and [ __ ] like that one of them is
is galvanizing that energy yeah and one
of them is just a piece of [ __ ]
right so one of them is a a flaming pile
of dog [ __ ] on your front porch and one
of them is just some regular dogs
like the flaming pile of dog [ __ ] could
light your whole house on fire
right right the other pile of dog [ __ ]
is just dog [ __ ] you could just clean it
up and you know it might not ruin your
entire house
that's a bar you feel me you better bar
up right now okay
so with the president though comes
so many other things like supreme court
justice for example
they just got this catholic [ __ ] up in
there who trump's trying to bring
in no no it's done okay yeah they pushed
her through okay
so now because of that there might not
be a
abortion might get taken off of the
[ __ ] roe versus wade might get
overturned
yeah so while you might not [ __ ] with
joe biden
because i don't [ __ ] with joe biden you
can dig up the tweets on me [ __ ] on
that man
i don't [ __ ] with joe biden yeah i don't
[ __ ] with kamala harris for the record
yeah i don't [ __ ] with her but
if they get elected it means that a
supreme court justice that won't
overturn abortion rights
or overturn gay marriage it's like
i hear you but i'm like look i'm a
bernie sanders [ __ ] right
i was rocking with bernie big bad bird
bernie and andrew yang
neither of them [ __ ] made it
through and i i'm
really i have a lot of disdain for the
dnc i think it's very corrupt
i think like the stuff you're saying
they feel very
uh entitled to black people's votes to
hispanic people's votes yeah
and they just take it for granted and
then they do this really
trash ass pandering with these
celebrities like shout out to two james
love two chains but the fact he went on
stage
by the way i think that might be the
second time he's done that's my dog
though
but what i'm saying is like i hear you
and you have every right to be like man
[ __ ] y'all
but i don't know if now's the time
if it was like just some normal
run-of-the-mill republican on the other
side
who wasn't on fire in front of your
house who could set your whole house on
fire
yeah if it was just a piece of [ __ ] and
a piece of [ __ ] well there's two
two pieces of [ __ ] here it's just really
a matter of you know
whether or not you want to sit the
election out but like [ __ ] is crazy dog
and i've seen you have interactions with
these
racist people i literally just um just
to figure out i literally just drove
past some trump dude we both like drew
down on each other he showed me he had
his gun and i showed him my mind
like okay can you hear me we weren't
ready [ __ ] i'm more ready
so so those people have always existed
the only thing about trump being
president is at least now
that we know who they are yeah like if
you see somebody with a flag hanging off
the back of their car
that's another level of like i
understand if you are
i don't understand if you're a trump
supporter but if you're a silent trump
supporter and you're just like yo i'm
voting for him for tax
whatever racism isn't a deal breaker
whatever
right but if you're the type of
[ __ ] that's out here with flags
hanging off your truck
that tells me you're a real racist
[ __ ] [ __ ] you kind of are about
something
you're about
i understand how you can be uninspired
but at the same time you have to
understand that like even if you
affected
20 people not voting that's a lot of
people
yeah and i think that if you take
even just the local measures those are
the measures that really affect
our day-to-day life like
that's where you got to like i hear you
yeah
you have the right to not vote you have
the right to say i'm just telling you i
i think that
you're a very smart dude and i
understand how you could feel like
these [ __ ] just think i'm just
supposed to vote for them because this
is who they're force-feeding me
and guess what that's how they feel
you're right these [ __ ]
really do just think like when this full
joe biden said if you don't vote if you
vote for donald trump you ain't black
that [ __ ] is insane
like the like how crazy was that
i love that the whistle for the people
who are gonna hear the podcast with no
video you got that whistle i'm gonna
give you another one but no
that was like i hear like a bomb at the
end of it no but that was exactly what
you were talking about
the fact that he had the audacity to say
that is like bruh
bro i'm gonna tell you like first off
i can't say that i disagree with what
you're saying
like you know what i mean um
by the way california's going blue
either way whether you vote or not but
no none of that
you continue regardless like i'm talking
about california
like but that's not that that's neither
here nor there true that's neither here
nor there
um
just to just to hit on the the dog [ __ ]
that's burning
in front of the the doorway first
just real quick too for me personally
and i believe for many
colored people that have grown up it
just
sounds really bad when you say colored
people yeah if not not as bad as if i
said it you don't know you already know
i hear you i know
you're pushing these you could say color
you could say melon knows you could say
black to me
saying black is worse than colored
that's fair i don't like it because
you're not black
yeah this is black right this is [ __ ]
black yeah that [ __ ] is not
tight i'm very like bronze real looking
i'm just i'm what they described to
jesus in the bible
you know what i'm saying literally but
so black ain't it but so
i don't know that's fair you know what i
mean um
i feel like the
burning [ __ ] has been in the front of
like literally every time i walk outside
of my door the burning shit's there bro
and this is not to like just try to like
you know say but it's just literally my
reality
it's equivalent to like
being
being to [ __ ] it i'll use it in regular
terms because i always
always use the analogy of like a castle
being taken and put into a castle and
putting at the bottom of the dungeon
and having to vote for who's at the top
of the couch [ __ ] that right imagine you
artists or you
um um personalities you bosses you
[ __ ] you're not a part you you got
your own [ __ ] studio company [ __ ]
father's husband
imagine you all being
me as an artist being taken to inner
school imagine interscope taking me
my rights everything and owning me
and they're like yo you gotta do what
the [ __ ] we say you like you know me
we own you you're in interscope right
period this is what the [ __ ] it is
and you want me to vote for who's like
the president of this company
i'm not voting for [ __ ] y'all y'all own
me regardless i'm here regardless that's
literally my
that's literally my perspective on
voting when you are a melanoid when you
are american african in this country
because the way i feel is this
neither of them and it's not hard the
same way you can reach out to little
pump because he's on
instagram making a hurrah about how he
[ __ ] with trump
so you feel the need to reach out to him
and bring him up for a [ __ ] rally
because he's made that much noise on
instagram do you know how much noise our
people have been making for reparations
on instagram alone
right i think [ __ ] ain't saying [ __ ]
about it [ __ ] y'all
i don't i'm not so for me what one thing
if you pay attention to me and you pay
attention to
the things that i truly post and you're
like literally paying attention
you see that i never press my view on
anything
i'm not a christian my family my mother
i'm a full-fledged christian but my
mother's a full-fledged christian i
fully believe in the christian faith i'm
just not a christian
right you know what i'm saying that's
not why i'm rocking i
rock go move how you move i never push
for people to do what i do
look do your history do your research
and then go with what
resonates with your god feeling that's
my biggest [ __ ] because literally
going down there and voting for anything
the one thing that we are doing we're in
san bernardino in the ie
we're getting involved with the
political side though we're with texas
especially in san bernardino county
there's some crazy trump [ __ ] going
on san bernardino county is the second
poorest county in the
second poor city in the united states
yeah and it is the biggest county
valley in san bernardino county no i was
in apple valley
at the homies crib and that [ __ ] was
real trumpy over there boy
yeah that's that's more like how
palmdale apple valley all that type of
[ __ ] yeah that's because
but see the ie is more of just like
being
well there's riverside county in san
bernardino county and so san bernardino
county is the biggest that might be
apple apple valley no no san bernardino
county damn train up available let me
tell you victorville is in san
bernardino
apple valley is an interesting place
yeah i could i don't think i'm wrong i
could be but i don't think so
correct me from wrong though look that
up because it was apple valley in san
bernardino county
but um by the way apple valley got got a
little trap area in it
everywhere it does definitely listen but
most definitely apple valley palmdale
lancaster you will get killed
out there it is not no game the same way
people think the ie is again i.e right
now is
number one the murder capital of
california if 2020 is san bernardino
not all the cities that everyone expects
the cities that are under not to just
try to parade
it's not cool but not to make [ __ ] cool
then it's
oakland and it's compton or then it's
compton oakland wanted him
but abba valley is in san bernardino san
bernardino
so but that's not like apple valley so
[ __ ] far but then again like i told
y'all san bernardino is the biggest
county in the united states
so it's so many [ __ ] little parts
that's what i'm saying that's why i
think if you're right when you vote in
those local because
i don't know i think that you're right i
think that uh
you're obviously i think reparations is
the big conversation that's right
that's the conversation it actually
isn't it and not
to catch on but i got to go in it there
isn't even
anything to talk about like and that's
the thing that i
as many as as well as many others from
boyce watkins to
tariq nishi to resi islam to it's too
many to name
young pharaoh max oh it's too many to
name that thorough be saying some wild
ass [ __ ]
well you know he does but most
definitely they're all can give you
a million facts as to why black
and how black people should and could be
in getting reparations this [ __ ] is like
childish and so for me
for black people to even
like know for like to even go down there
and play
any of them games to even be in any
political
seat is just scary but at the same time
we gotta play ball
we play the [ __ ] is nuts it's a rat race
but
that's why for me what the number one
thing we push is
ownership the number one thing we push
is obviously like i said is
getting down there and get there are
people who feel like i feel
have way more knowledge than i have as
far as african spirituality and history
that go and vote and they're pushing for
people to vote and i'm not mad at that
because it's true to them i'm literally
selling my soul i feel like i am
selling my soul going down to them let
me ask you a question
don't sell your soul going to the puzzle
i'm just playing yo
we're uh breaking down this video we're
not breaking it down we're taking a
break in the video
to tell you all about our sponsors odd
socks all right listen man
uh odd socks official.com what the [ __ ]
was that bro
uh it was like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair
floating in air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable uh
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time is on the way
use the keyword boulet kev 20 off odd
socks official dot com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go no no but like
i've i know you're extr you've been
extremely vocal about trump over the
last four years
i kind of [ __ ] with trump a little if
we're talking trump or biden
well no but well that's crazy uh but
know what i was going to say but no but
bro you've been very vocal online about
the trump [ __ ] yeah
over the last four years do you think
you've started to pivot your
thought process on it more recently
because of biden getting a
like i do feel like the the dnc
heavily like fumbled the play at the i
mean look they're probably going to win
it's looking like biden's winning um but
they could have like scraped scraped i'm
talking about
officers because it's all designed
listen hear me i didn't vote for obama
i'm not registered to vote period what
i'm saying i didn't vote for obama
have you softened your trump stance
lately no only thing that it made me do
is be like all right well [ __ ] if i
gotta if i wanna if if
one out of two of these [ __ ]
got to be in there i'd rather trump be
in there
why because for me like you said one
thing
just off rip if i got to deal with
racist half races play racist faker
i'd rather deal with the raw races i'd
rather deal with rather know who you are
i love knowing who people are if you're
gay be gay and just be
gay very gay so we know you're gay don't
be the homie and you
you know what i'm saying you on the down
low and [ __ ] you doing some wild [ __ ]
like nah be gay
whatever you are be it that's how i'm
coming so trump is
it if he's nothing else he's it and then
the thing that trump
the one thing i can say about trump out
of damn near any president i've ever
seen
other than obama creating obamacare
which was in the benefit of
all the [ __ ] but again
he got voted in yeah and that but that
was by design
um obama was going to win regardless i'm
not sure that's the case that was
that was the case just like trump was
going to win regardless
but trump's losing right now i i think
it's a wrap i'm talking about this one
but i think trump
i think the by design would have been
trump getting don't think trump's going
to work
i'm talking about trump versus no but i
don't i don't i just don't know i just
can't i just can't uh
i don't think it was by design that hit
bro trump versus hillary
was definitely trump scraped you here's
my question
you talk about trump being in there you
know he's a racist and biden is like an
undercover racist what you're saying
now policy wise when trump starts
pushing policies
that are directly racist and repealing
human rights for certain people
um biden if he's trying to play
undercover races he's not going to be
able to directly do that
right i don't think the people in his
cabinet or the people on his side are
going to be pushing those types of
policies i agree the reason why i [ __ ]
with biden is obviously for things of
like the deport deportation
right these i got not only hispanic
companies but i got african friends i
got
egyptian homies one of my best friends
is egyptian and like you know what i'm
saying
it's like wild [ __ ] like that that i
don't want to happen to my people
most definitely however
the struggle that comes above and before
all of that
is the american african struggle that
has yet to been answered at all
so i could give personally a [ __ ] about
any of it not a gay right
not a woman right not a no right until
black rights are
respecting the answer that's truly how i
feel bro and i've got to be
like one of the people that's going to
say i'm independent so y'all can't hurt
me
what y'all want to do i do think i think
that trump has done a couple of things
uh he increased the funding for
historical black colleges for the hbcus
he got his little [ __ ] platinum plan
he tried to work out
nah that's all [ __ ] you're gonna
follow through though i'm talking about
[ __ ] he's actually yeah he had four
years to do that he's gonna go
i'm telling my [ __ ] he's actually done
he he funded the [ __ ] out of the hbcus
which nobody's done
yeah and then he um he had the prison
reform bill that that benefits
colored people as you would say there's
a few things that like
i mean like if we're going off of track
records
now the one thing that trump trump's an
idiot that's
clear as day he is a racist
um for sure he has no empathy is my
biggest problem with trump
yeah he has no empathy but he's also
like a businessman
first and when you're a businessman
there's a
certain level of empathy like you gotta
have empathy i have empathy
no trump ain't got no empathy but he
he's such a like
raw because he's like you gotta
understand this nigga's been rich since
before we were
i was born like the man's got small dick
energy little rascals up
cis little rascal that [ __ ] was in
little rascals bro for sure i remember
this [ __ ]
having to be this like snobby boss so
it's nothing for him to like not give a
[ __ ] about what's not benefiting
whether it's the business but now the
business is the country
yeah i don't know man so for me i'm not
saying that i'm [ __ ] with it or i'm
[ __ ] with him or
like but i do like i get the logic of
um and then he's not a politician so
that part of the game i do [ __ ] with too
because probably like like prime example
is nobody when i do [ __ ]
take time out of my [ __ ] amazing life
this
incredible colored experience to watch
these goofballs
[ __ ] have the most childish debate
i've ever seen since
my nine-year-old argument was the first
debate both
no the first date was the first
but that's because trump and biden
because if biden wasn't childish and
corny he wouldn't even be partaking
me i would have walked off the stage i'm
not even doing this let's get this [ __ ]
like
what are we doing when you guys are
ready to do this professionally but
that's the thing
biden gets up there and plays the
politician game
answers everything like the last hundred
[ __ ] we've been seeing for the last
hundred years
i can't play that game i mean i
understand you just have now you sound
more like barack
that's the thing he's got into steady
barack watch your necks next time
he talks if you make a sound trump is
the president
the worst thing that can happen to me is
like the
end of the united states the end of
democracy possibly the end of the world
because this guy might
somebody might say some [ __ ] about his
little hands and he might
turn the [ __ ] up and hit the red button
on him i mean what stopped that from the
first four years
everybody thought that was going to have
election first free elections presidents
always do their most extreme
policies and choices in their second
term because they're not for re-election
it doesn't matter no but you also
i don't know if you noticed but trump
low-key almost got us into world war
three
when he assassinated the the general of
iran without clearing it through
[ __ ] anybody like that
we're so lucky that iran like
didn't want the smoke because if they
wanted to smoke they got china and
russia
[ __ ] was about to be turned we literally
smug it'd be like
if somebody came over here and smoked
mike pence
and they was like bro cuz that was that
guy's position essentially
in iran was like the number two in the
whole country is a [ __ ] hero in the
country
yeah and we smoked him for no reason
so that's the thing i would rather you
say i like we
but not we if anybody y'all okay donald
trump
them but
no bro we can't do that we
can't do that for you or anybody or your
listeners these beautiful beautiful
beautiful bootleg kev podcast listeners
i won't even do that to y'all make y'all
believe that trump
just picked his phone up and made a
single
solo did you not see him speak about it
trump can't just make that call so
understand overstanding understanding is
if someone
got assassinated especially at number
two anybody at mike pence's level from
any country he he
but listen he's the commander he's
deeper than trump he's the
commander-in-chief so he's he's
military he's the leader of the military
he cleared
that action through neither the senate
or the
or congresswoman right what he's saying
is that there's other military advisors
there
but what i'm saying is so much deeper
detection kind of [ __ ]
we're talking about what we're talking
about we're talking about
so who do we have at the end of the day
this motherfucker's losing today so [ __ ]
him
yeah facts but lick it but what we need
to really truly be
looking at which is the same reason why
i'm looking at them
this is who my enemy is this is who i
truly am looking i'm not looking at
trump
i'm looking at the foolish [ __ ] like
government that put him in position it's
not the people
the people didn't put him there so the
people did put him there people did
but listen no they did not but look it
what you're telling me is a [ __ ]
who has no
political experience and you get to
wondering if he's that actual
actual [ __ ] like school experience
like no he's like he's like slow
right and so you mean to tell me that
the country the government
allowed this man that's why i come in
within four years
and outsmart them in another price price
this is the thing who are we mad and he
said the people didn't do it that's why
that happened
every single established republican
every single one all of them
were against him becoming the nomination
everybody there was not a a single
established
republican politician or politician
period
that when the republican primary went
down they
trump had the people chose him what
happened was
these [ __ ] that you had to draw
down on today these crazy racist
bastards they came out in droves that
nobody expected to happen
facts and so when you say the people the
people
maybe not the majority of the people
because we have electoral college
but hello but hello the people is who
that's who put them there so the same
way hold on the same amount of
people and racist [ __ ] beer drinking
fat belly guzzling [ __ ] hey
uh uh [ __ ] redneck cracker [ __ ]
weird dudes that came popping up out of
nowhere to go
vote for trump because we got to get
this dude in here one
because he's a racist like us but two
because we will not stand for seeing a
woman
white or black run our country they got
out there
campaign for trump yes they did oh they
did it yes they did
however way way way way way way more
women alone black white mexican asian
any type of woman
were at those polls voting for [ __ ]
hillary and everything
that's not true that's very true hey
what more white women voted
listen maybe white women but what i'm
saying but you said all you said
all right that's so cool maybe some
white women and not all white women but
maybe some women more white women voted
for trump this go round than they did
maybe because that's that's that goes to
show you how this country is
right yeah white man because you got to
understand something that's the reason
why i knew obama was going to win
it was nothing to vote because white men
uh um historical white men these racists
[ __ ] they're
the racist slave masters the the
forefathers i mean the
descendants of the slave masters
they will not stand for a white woman
a woman to run the country that's just
not happening they're not having
not saying it won't happen but they're
going to do anything in their power
before they'll rather see a [ __ ]
running ready
running against you talking about sarah
palin no when hillary
when obama
like probably the most it was a
no-brainer
articulate candidate like you there's
not a more likable candidate
than barack obama whether or not you
think he was a good president
but if you just were to sit in a room a
dude yeah
chop it up with him but sadly this you'd
be like yo i [ __ ] with i [ __ ] with
barack most definitely but sadly you
know michelle got [ __ ] black star on
her playlist
but the reality is this shit's not about
who [ __ ] like because everybody really
likes bernie
if we're talking about who really you
know but who don't really like bernie
the problem is the southern older
democrats
they're they've been so indoctrinated by
the dnc
that they're like biden
so that's the whole reason bernie lost
south carolina that south carolina
primary
because biden is a part of like that
same
establishment come on but all the people
we
political foolishness the same reason
why kamala harris will get on camera and
lie about her favorite rappers and [ __ ]
to play the game
well it's also the same reason why you
feel like you don't want to vote
the same reason why i'm not going to
vote well you should vote man
you're a smart guy they should i am
which is why i know better for me
personally i know better
i know better yeah so what i know to do
for my people and what we are doing let
me ask you something what is the number
one thing in
in in in that you experience in la
that is like impedes or affects your
peace every day
i'm not talking about i'm talking about
tangible things
i'm talking about like what's something
like for me it's when i drive
and i see like full homeless people
cities under the bridges
like and i'm like yo fam like thank god
my kid don't gotta walk to school
through here because these [ __ ]
are shooting hearing on the side of the
road
and mayor garcetti is pretty much
you can't do nothing like that like like
the the police force
like literally can't do anything about
it yeah it's a whole community it's a
liquor store
right so that's my example right right
so i'm like okay
those kind of things collectively you
can vote to change
yeah so what [ __ ] me because you ask me
a question so what [ __ ] me up
like what makes me feel like the most
uh when i leave like a prime example is
that right but
when i see that what [ __ ] me up isn't
the fact that i can't
get them up or make them leave it's the
fact that they're there
it's the fact that like my people when i
see black people because that's who i
give my money to my right all right
when i see colored people how did you
get there it's the fact that you're
there
it's the fact that you don't own land
it's the fact that you don't even have
your 40 acres in the middle you didn't
even get to jump start with that
now whether or not you just ended here
because you [ __ ] your 40 acres off or
whatever was owed to you
like the indians get like jews and many
too many to name
then that'd be a different convo but due
to the fact that i know how our people
where we come from dog when i drive down
skid row because
that was going to be my answer what
[ __ ] me up every day is the fact that
my
family the people i got to do i just had
to fire my cousin off my food truck
after two weeks three weeks whatever of
trying my hardest to [ __ ]
deal with them right right where we're
at yeah we got those family members all
day
it's literally a psychological bond
psychological bondage that we're in dog
that is like
it's not a pity party it's not me like
trying to make excuses
you know what i'm saying because he's
like that because his dad is how his dad
is and it's genetic
so let me ask you residuals from
american history so what you're saying
is
all our residuals are [ __ ] poison
it's crack
it's rape it's incest it's [ __ ] pain
is is
is trauma that's our residuals that's
the reparations we've been given we
can't get no money they [ __ ] want to
give edd
and [ __ ] that [ __ ] well listen
i think that there's no uh
what you're talking about there might
not be a uh
it's a solution no well don't go ahead
what do you think the solution is then
because i don't think that there's
a a clear-cut solution yeah it is what
is it it's very clear that's what my
album talks about that's what color it
is that's what this whole [ __ ] is about
it's what it stands for
it's black ownership it's leaving a
legacy it's financial freedom
residual income that is the [ __ ]
answer
not voting what the [ __ ] listen voting
does not give you any like okay whether
you win
whether you win and voted because y'all
gonna blame it on me y'all gonna y'all
are going to blame it on my one vote
as to why the rent went up in california
and that
in that in that price by the way y'all
gonna blame it on my one vote or me
telling my people which i
reposted on my story those props
okay but y'all but but the people don't
blame it on me
as my one vote as to why rent went rent
king is possibly going to go up in
california now
but guess what black man black woman if
you had ownership
if you had a company if you had
businesses you had residual income
that wouldn't be a problem to you
because i could give a [ __ ] about rent
going up in california
period so that's what i'm pushing that's
the answer because if i had a million
dollars
that i can that i can literally like cut
a check right now that wouldn't like
that wouldn't make me lose no sleep
or even if it did make me lose some
sleep but it was for my [ __ ]
people
and my cousin did and i could call my
bro bobby that does
and i could call five and ten of my
homies that got a m
we wouldn't even have to talk about all
this [ __ ] because we'd have our own
party
we'd have our own political party then
it'd be established we wouldn't have to
wait on diddy he'll let you to death we
wouldn't have to wait on ross we
wouldn't have to wait on none of these
[ __ ]
there's no ownership bro there's no
financial freedom my sons
are going to own so i have [ __ ] no i
mean i think that's absolutely i think
that that's
that's a great solution i think though
that like when you're talking about like
any sort of incremental progress no
matter how small it is
yeah it's still progress like in in my
opinion like okay oregon just
i don't know if you saw that oregon made
it to where drug possession if you
if you have personal use drugs no matter
what it is that they don't treat it
as a criminal offense that's fire right
because like
that can be fireworks no but i mean they
make you go to like therapy
and court court mandated
rehab essentially right instead of
ruining your
job application of fire bro well i'm
gonna just say i'm just picking back
what you're saying because i'm gonna say
like
people who are addicted to drugs are
going through things and they're trying
to get over it whatever whatever getting
caught with drugs and then
having to get all this crazy time that's
one thing but [ __ ] who are literally
waking up every day and their intention
is to sell dope and [ __ ] that's killing
people
i'm not talking no no no it's about
users it's perfect it's personal
i'll tell right recently portugal
i think it was like 10 years ago or
something they decriminalized all drugs
across the board
and crime as a whole plummeted fire
not just went down and plummeted because
what happens is now you have users who
aren't afraid to go seek help
because it's no longer illegal right so
the punishment and stuff is not there i
think too it helps with poverty because
if you think about this how many people
you know they got caught with some with
some [ __ ] some pills or some crack or
whatever and then now
[ __ ] up their jobs they can't get their
job they can't get a job because they're
failing yeah
facts and so it's like so that to me is
like an example of like local government
working even if it's a small increment
like i understand what you're saying
isn't wrong but both things can be right
yeah like isn't it any progress yeah and
even though it's just your one single
vote
is still even if it makes
a little bit of a difference in the in
like it's not it's like right now
like four like okay you turn my
ownership right yeah so if there was
something on the ballot
that like uh
incentivized black ownership small
business
small like that would you still not vote
me personally there was stuff on i've
seen different ballets different parts
so that's a difference
you didn't move the needle for you to
want to go vote it's not enough i don't
give a [ __ ] about it but isn't it
something
it's not enough i'm not saying that so
you're saying it's either look i'm
either
yeah listen listen to what you're like
this is this is the logic to me
this is the logic to me because no no
this is logic to me
this is the logic to me my grandfather
worked for you
my grandfather worked for your
grandfather for
his whole life not only did my
grandfather not saying you know i'm just
speaking i'm just using an example
not only did your grandfather my
grandfather work for your grandfather
for his whole life but your grandfather
and his buddies
beat his ass raped his wife did all type
of [ __ ] with it which we all know
which was done but not only did he do
that after he did all the trauma she did
he got a fake little heart and attempted
to write a note that said
hey i'm gonna make right of what i did
so for you and your generations to come
this is what's owed to you guys because
you worked all your life for me you
have businesses so imagine your [ __ ]
staff oh cause i think about it all the
time
working i wish my staff would work a
week for free right right
oh my god [ __ ] what let alone a year
four years forty four hundred what are
we doing
wait wait so what you're telling me is
that like so now we get here
you owe me a million dollars bro
so there is no all right no no but i'm
gonna give you all these laptops and let
you come to the no no no
y'all owe us a million dollars like um
uh
the radio station vegas if they owe you
a check
you're you need your check because you
and your wife have in your son
y'all have to move out here and get
married you're paying for your wedding
you have a wedding ring to buy what can
we talk no i don't need no turntables
[ __ ] y'all owe me a check that y'all
said was mine
and oh to me i did the work and y'all
start to sit to me [ __ ] but
it's my so i don't want to take no
little there's none of that that none of
that's enough it's
never amusing not even a black president
that [ __ ] ain't enough i don't give a
[ __ ]
right get from down there by obama get
from down there get over here and stand
with us man what the [ __ ] are you doing
up there
diddy get from two chains leave
little pump up there leave them [ __ ]
where they at y'all get over here and
get on cold
that's what i'm talking about about
ownership i'm not waiting on them we're
opening schools in my city
we got businesses in my city we talking
to the council we literally my school
that we're opening city right shout out
to my partner cherise wright
city right come university opening our
school which is across the street from
city hall
in san bernardino we coming but i'm not
about to go down to the polls and play
the baby game
while we no i'm not doing that i'm going
to go make real moves
i'm going to make real plays i'm going
to give my people the blueprint on how
to help make these plays
help make them real because the more
money we all got standing together
the louder our voice is we talking all
the [ __ ] we talk about it's too many
broke [ __ ] that's yelling it
out or
people without enough power not enough
ownership like the person that owned bt
i forgot my brother's name
no the black man now some johnson i
forget i'll forget his name but yeah i
wrote a little code a little planned out
billion dollar [ __ ] reparation plan
whatever but it got
attention why did it get attention
because it's coming from a billionaire
who owned bt so imagine if 10 of him
if 10 of brothers that are just in the
position
here and all locked up so price that's
all i'm saying
in order for reparations to happen is is
something that's going to have to go
through the political process
yeah that's that's that's there's
there's no avoiding the political
process
for what you want right so like
for reparations to happen that's
something that has to go through
congress
has to go through the scene yeah it has
to get proposed that's the only thing
hold on just to just just because i
don't even want to that's not even
necessarily just oh
something i want because to me that's
not like i'm looking for a person
that literally raped my whole family i
understand so that's not going to happen
what i'm saying is that there is a
realistic chance that in our lifetime
that does happen yeah i believe
because we got uh you know there's a
very progressive wing of the democratic
party that's that's activated
and maybe in 20 years you know 10 years
the country can start to come around to
that because like you said
there has been reparations for native
americans
and and germany had to i was just having
this discussion the reason why
um america won't acknowledge the turkish
genocide to happen
is because that would stamp it as being
factual and then turkey
would have to pay armenians out with
their reparations
so you're right you're saying you're
owed that but what i'm saying is that's
still a political
it's still go you still got to vote to
try to put the right people in place to
try to help that happen
yeah but the power like i said the power
and the the power and the loudness
the the if joe biden was like i want
reparations we're going to fight for
reparations would you have gone and
voted or would have been like [ __ ] this
if he had a real plan and he was
campaigning for operations
i would 100 when he voted right 100 when
he voted
that's all that we were listening there
was a whole campaign that people
in our community were campaigning for
tangibles 2020.
there was a lot of that was the campaign
tangible's 2020. but there was a lot of
democratic uh
people who were running in the primary
that had some solid plans for
reparations
yeah the uh governor from
the billionaire from seattle and uh the
governor from
colorado uh i forget their names but
nobody was voting for them yeah
because i mean i'm not going to say
because i don't know i don't know people
i know pete budad said that he thinks
that reparations need to happen
but those guys because the higher ups
because then when he gets to higher ups
[ __ ] get the dude
nick you ask biting you ask the [ __ ]
is running for president not saying that
it's just about them but you asked the
people running for president with how
they feel about reparations you get
those and
i don't think that this should be that i
don't think it should be this that's
what i'm saying
we got people up there that are still
alive when we had segregation my point
hold on
and not only that that's the point
bro i had a debate with my brother aaron
foster
you know what i'm saying shout out to
the houston tv shout out to my brother
he's so that's
[ __ ] me over in fantasy football a
couple of years so [ __ ] smart bro
very smart very sweet people don't very
well yo
yo he's like i love following him on
twitter instagram super smart
he's great [ __ ] me up because i'm not
a college kid i'm from nowhere what's
your big football player all my
knowledge all my information i have
obtained i just got so much to learn but
everything i've obtained i've obtained
it i went and
sought after it i wouldn't got it i
didn't go to school my brother was
chewing me on some
[ __ ] vernacular was out of here he was
going crazy but you know
he's so smart but just saying that to
say when i did my research because we
did a debate so i did 12 hours of
research you know i mean
it's people sitting at the top of the
senate bro they've literally been there
since [ __ ] they've been a 67
like been there from the beginning
they're no doubt races
right that are over the trumps and [ __ ]
like that's what i think most of the
people who have been around that long
aren't there anything they are there is
nothing to think about i'ma send them to
you
i mean there's like michelle mcconnell
and there's like lindsey graham now
listen there was this
old fool yes bro there was this i'm
assuming no no i i i think that there
definitely was but i think no they're
there still
they're there still i pulled it out and
when our debate i'm just i i have so
much [ __ ] that i
but but those people are there because
because [ __ ]
voted them in yeah
what he's saying is 100 effect as far as
like
the power of the voting [ __ ] i'm not i'm
not negating as far as at a city level
right at a city level and at a lower
level i'm not negating that okay because
the reason why it's a real thing
as we were just looking at our school um
and they're telling us you know we're
across the street from city council
blah blah city hall the person that just
won the city council
and um i don't know if they keep winning
it or just won whatever the [ __ ]
they won by eight votes literally eight
votes yeah eight people one eight people
wouldn't vote
so y'all think y'all i didn't hear that
and get turnt the [ __ ] up like oh really
but i'm gonna play the game because this
is a game
going down there and polling but the
political [ __ ] is a game so if
i'm gonna play a game one i'm gonna play
a game i wanna play
xbox playstation i'm gonna play one i
wanna play then
but then beyond that then i'm going to
play the game i want to play within that
call of duty
uh nba 2k yeah but this game is a game
that can affect your day-to-day life
it can affect people who knows life it
it can
but it can't affect it no more than it
already affects it with me
waking up with the color skin i have
right and them
already not making right to what's been
done bro
that's this that's the that's the
beginning combo i understand what you're
talking about
we're talking about forgiving your
girlfriend that's not what i'm talking
about that is
that's what i'm saying because we're
talking about so much deeper than that i
i get it right what you're saying is but
what i'm i'm not talking about that i'm
talking about
like we're coming for city council
i use the weed example that's what i'm
saying like these are things that like
i'm with that would like would you
rather not vote
or like make sure wheat is legal i mean
i'm going to smoke weed regardless i
don't care yeah but that's not
wouldn't you rather not risk going to
jail for smoking what's
something yeah that would be awesome so
shouldn't you vote
no i'm right i am
it doesn't make you it makes you feel
one there's enough people that's why
that's what like we make up yes 13 of
population we definitely do
we definitely do but we make up 13 of
the population
that's it but like 60 something percent
of the prison population due to yeah
but that's also due to this government
that's still slavery
that's right so if we get rid of the
laws that they're pushing some of that
can be reduced unfortunately
definitely however however
if weeds gonna be legal weeds gonna be
legal the reason why we use legal is not
because they wanna let us smoke weed
out on the street and not arrest us weed
is legal because they want to be able to
sell it and profit off of it how do i
know because they're charging me and my
company [ __ ]
hundreds of thousands to get in this
space so it's not for us
but so i'm able to see past that y'all
are y'all residual effect though
y'all are making gay those same weed
uh propositions that pass in california
because we're liberal as [ __ ]
have been on ballots in states for the
last 15 years and
don't get passed most definitely like
georgia has tried to pass
legal marijuana for [ __ ] ever you got
arrested in georgia
because you got people that are sitting
in those seats you got people not
[ __ ] voting
you got people that no you got people
that are sitting in those seats
that are at the top of the [ __ ] which
the top of the these government seats
any of these [ __ ]
in atlanta atlantis atlanta when i lived
in atlanta that was one of the first
places i've seen an actual [ __ ] kkk
rally in stone mountain
that's one of the that it's plantation
still in atlanta
they're going to be some of the last
people to you know they're going to be
any
any any of those they're not atlanta was
the example i put out of my ass no
well i'm using atlanta because it's
perfect because atlanta is like atlanta
and
the texas is the i mean surprisingly
arizona
which not even surprisingly hey man
listen shout out to arizona the
south we blew baby south i grew up in
florida exactly
the south are going to be some of the
last ones to
like get on board with what we do in
california is california
so it doesn't surprise me
that um like places like jersey and
different places like that are
legalizing and then atlanta is not
because one atlanta
they they're orlando so the
[ __ ] that have been that are in
these government positions political
positions
in atlanta that have been there that
have been there
they're not in any rush for any [ __ ]
weed [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ]
to them we'd still like crack so they
don't see anything that's why you gotta
get the [ __ ] up out of there
i don't give a [ __ ] all these people are
elected officials
all of them most definitely all the
people you're talking about were elected
yeah man so there was someone who but
bro this is the thing
this is the reality this is one reality
as much as i think the reality is
as much as what you're saying is a
reality yeah right
what also isn't like a very much of a
reality bro is what
you're saying and what's being said has
been being said
for decades now but we have not many
people
decades now bro no black people have not
made [ __ ] progress no
no it's not a wee combo that's the thing
bro
you my brother but it's not a wii combo
this particular conversation
ain't a wee one that's what i'm saying
every [ __ ] um
everything that they keep presenting for
black people all has something to do
with minority this ain't a minority
convo we're talking about american
africans
that are descendants of slaves right
we need ours so until then no i
shouldn't vote for [ __ ]
going on there's going to be enough
people out there that's going to do it
for my soul because i'm one of the ones
i'm one of the ones bro i'm one of the
ones that are going to help
revolutionize and save our people
[Music]
if a presidential candidate were to come
if if a presidential candidate came to
the table and was like i'm pushing for
reparations
here's my plan then you would vote then
you got do you have my attention you got
this you got my attention
then you have me rallying up our people
because we were rallying
pushing for reparations which is how i
know they're ignoring us
because if that wasn't the bar of
analogies i don't know what it is
little pump ain't even been campaigning
for trump that shit's been two weeks
long
not for sure this little [ __ ] ended up
on the [ __ ] rally stage that's crazy
at the at the day of election time well
that's why we got to get that's why i
don't know
i'm like so that goes to tell you
they're ignoring us
they're ignoring this so once we do got
somebody like that bro
because even obama didn't get up there
and do that why because he couldn't
hands by his back and he wasn't bold
enough
is there another because i think too the
the biggest thing
um that i he's a politician so people
that i know
um you know people who i'm close with
people i consider family are affected by
the the the justice system right
and i think that that is a very
important
issue maybe maybe not on the level of
reparations but i think
it's important though it's up there it's
this it's modern-day slavery
i agree yeah right and and specifically
prison for you know prisons for profits
like people like this is privately owned
prisons
or you could buy i think you could buy
stock in some of these companies on
prisons i would not doubt it
so that is that so that's an
to me that's like an issue that can be
can that that there's there's definitive
politicians
like bernie sanders right who's like a
definitive politician that's like
has a real plan to like do away with
that
right because we know that people of
color are disproportionately
locked up compared to uh white people
100 despite
exactly right so isn't that
something that's worth stepping out and
voting for or
or like someone like bernie who comes
along who's got some practical like
ideas been fighting the same like like
like it just depends on
one the answer's still no but the reason
why it's no is because it just depends
on the state that
american africans are in in this country
man that's going to determine when
i personally think that we should be
getting out here and campaigning as a
as like a free people as like a as like
it's fair
like it's not fair still so to me when
i'm going to the polls
and i'm participating in this circus
for to me but in this thing that is
supposed to be in a nation that's free
and
justice and you unity and all this [ __ ]
it ain't that so no
all right that [ __ ] just ain't it bro
well listen i i mean we all got our
our our perspective but the beauty is
this bro i don't push for
people not to vote i push for you to do
what's true to you if you are american
african
do your research because if you do
enough research you're going to know
what i'm saying is a hundred percent
true and it's gonna hit your spirit
and you're gonna get on cold it's that's
or you're not
because you're not gonna do the research
you don't give a [ __ ] and that's okay
go vote and do your thing because you're
gonna feel you're gonna have that fight
for black people and go vote and that's
cool go do that and let's see what
happens all right well look your album
is out
colored out now uh when is the second
album coming out
man damn i'ma chill cause drake dropping
so who knows you're gonna wait till
drake
i don't i'm not gonna wait i'm just
going to kind of like see where the wave
goes
yeah it didn't like like not waiting for
but exactly right now i know
you feel me just see where that wave
going hello yeah just push this
let's at least push this the rest of the
year no we're going crazy sure maybe
it's happening
what's the website people can go scoop
up that c-l-r-g-e-n-t dot-com
that's the label man we the millennial
motown um
i'm coming bro that's all about
ownership we go on everything
and it's audio push a rap not as like a
brotherhood but like
will there be ever be any more audio
push projects albums or if you guys kind
of move past that
it will be but i don't you know i can't
i'm so
in this world right now i can't really
say that's fair you know what i'm saying
i'm just like locked in i get with
like when i used to see my favorite
group say [ __ ] like this but not be
broken up i get it like
you know what i'm saying because it's
like i'm in the world now
you know i mean that i can't that's like
true to me i got a real message i'll
make an audio push out of a [ __ ] win
enough of my [ __ ] got millions for
sure ownership you know
right well shout out to uh to to you bro
come and know you got some [ __ ] martin's
got some [ __ ] on the way are you coming
that's my [ __ ] hell of a hell of a tech
deck writer that octane
oh yeah [ __ ] crazy with the crazy shout
out to birdy hunters man shout out to
carrie's barbecue shout out to city
recording studios shout out to city
right come university that's the school
that's coming
shout out to like all your [ __ ] lounge
24 them all the companies man shout out
to colored ent
support man yeah man oh my god yeah
boom my brother perfect that was fire